governor sysolak announcing all nevadans
age 16 and up will be eligible for the
vaccine
on april 5th orco mana joins us live
with the details tonight in tonight's
top story
orco well sasha and brian
nevadans aged 16 and older who have
underlying medical conditions will start
being able to get the vaccine
on monday and then in just two and a
half weeks from that from now
16 and older nevadans will be able to
get the vaccine
and this is a timeline many have been
waiting for
it makes me feel very safe a light at
the end of the tunnel
governor steve sisolak announcing all
nevadan 16 and older can get the covet
19 vaccine
starting on april 5th it will bring
happiness
32 year old makeup artist justine hill
often works with masculist clients
she's thrilled to soon be eligible for
the vaccine so she doesn't have to worry
about bringing the virus back to her
family
my mom is 69 and she does live with me
so
it's nice to be able to have that peace
of mind that
i won't get her sick and get my kids
sick as well the end is in sight
nevada we can do this governor sysolak
saying nevada is now getting nearly 65
000 doses a week from the federal
government and with more shipments
coming soon he's hopeful for the future
nevada will be the safest place to have
a convention
or come and visit will be safe for the
tourists
and business travelers will be safe for
employees
and will be safe for their families
business leaders encouraging those in
the retail and restaurant industry who
are currently eligible to make
appointments now
so that there are even more appointments
available for the folks that just became
eligible or will become eligible on
monday
nevadans like justine can't wait it's
going to be nice to be able to know that
i'm not transmitting it to anyone
now governor sislek wants to stress that
the actual availability of appointments
still depends on the allocation of the
vaccine we get from the federal
government so he's asking everyone
to be patient with the process he does
say that we are expecting to get more
doses
in april reporting live tonight orgomana
8 news now